just hours before queen elizabeth's  death a beautiful double rainbow  appeared over buckingham palace  the crowds gathered and the most  significant change of course  the flagpole above buckingham palace  where the union flag  has now been lowered as people gathered  outside the gates to await news about  the monarch's condition they witnessed  the phenomenon which appeared after dark  clouds and rainfall turned into bursts  of sunshine many calling it a sign of  good news to come while others think it  symbolizes her majesty crossing the  rainbow bridge  but not long after that stunning sky  buckingham palace revealed the queen had  died surrounded by family quote the  queen died peacefully at balmoral this  afternoon the king and the queen consort  will remain at balmoral this evening and  will return to london tomorrow  the british monarch is survived by her  four kids charles andrew ann and edward  along with eight grandchildren and  twelve great-grandchildren  [Music]  you